[Musique]
le chômage la pauvreté les impôts la
dette l'insécurité ont explosé chaque
gouvernement a laissé la france dans un
état pire qui nous l'a trouvé les
gouvernements font semblant de gouverner
les gouvernements ont abandonné le
pouvoir ils l'ont abandonnée à des
autorités non élus ils ont abandonné à
bruxelles
ils ont abandonné auprès des marchés
financiers ces puissances de l'argent
qu'ils ont capturé notre électricité
notre gars nos autoroutes notre
compagnie pétrolière je m'appelle
nicolas dupont aignan je suis marié à
valérie et père de deux filles depuis 17
ans je suis maire de la ville de yerres
dans l'essonne
je suis gaulliste député depuis 15 ans
ma différence je n'ai jamais accepté
aucune des compromissions des grands
partis je n'ai jamais tenu un double
langage vis-à-vis de mes compatriotes
j'ai toujours voté dans l'idée que je me
fais de l'intérêt général
j'ai souvent résister quand les autres
députés obéissaient aux consignes de
leur parti c'est cette liberté et cette
indépendance qui me permettent de vous
parler aujourd'hui
en toute sincérité de vous dire une
vérité que d'autres vous cache cette
triste vérité
nos gouvernements successifs ont peu à
peu abandonné les pouvoirs du peuple
français à des bureaucrates non élus et
aux marchés financiers la monnaie
le contrôle de nos frontières et
maintenant l'impôt avant d'écouter les
belles paroles des uns et des autres
souvenez-vous simplement de leurs actes
gauche comme droite
ils ont signé tous les traités européens
qui sont à l'origine de notre déclin et
ils se plaignent des effets de leur
décision ils se plaignent de la montée
des extrêmes de l'abstention maintenant
notre pays est au pied du mur
le choix n'a jamais été aussi simple
pour la france
soit nous restons sur la voie tracée
depuis 30 ans et pour survivre dans la
mondialisation nous alignons nos
salaires sur ceux de l' esclavage
humains en chine
bien qu'il se refuse à l'admettre c'est
le choix des candidats du passé soit
nous disons stop et nous appliquons un
protectionnisme intelligent
aux pays qui ne respectent pas les
règles du jeu c'est mon choix car je me
refuse à détruire un modèle social qui
fait notre fierté c'est pourquoi je suis
candidat à la présidence de la
république candidat pour rendre à la
france sa liberté d'agir
notre pays a des atouts si nous décidons
par nous mêmes nous pourrons sortir de
la crise oui nous pourrons relocaliser
l'emploi défendre le pouvoir d'achat
reconstruire l'école pour tous assurer
la sécurité des français
faire vivre nos services publics sur
tout le territoire de métropole et
d'outre-mer rassembler les français
autour de nos belles valeurs
républicaines telle est mon projet et
c'est au premier tour le 22 avril que
vous pourrez exprimer vos convictions
que vous pourrez pesé pour changer les
choses dans notre pays
aujourd'hui nous sommes peut être un peu
plus petit que les autres mais l'arbre
est planté bien coup droit il est
enraciné dans les profondeurs du pays de
la liberté et du rassemble
de la démocratie au service de l'intérêt
général
alors oui reprenez le pouvoir pour
l'amour de la france vive la république
vive la france
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]